yeah with more on the democrats
soviet-style secret impeachment coup
attempt plus all the breaking news
tonight about durham horowitz's probes
with the great one mark levin mark i got
her just first ask a question then i'm
gonna let you go my friend
all right Pfizer reports coming out but
now we have the Justice Department have
now shifted this review of the origins
of the Russian witch-hunt and that means
the prosecutor running at John Durham
has the power for subpoena for witnesses
testimony documents he can panel a grand
jury and file charges this is huge
your reaction first of all I won't be
voting for her I'll be voting for Donald
Trump just just wanted to know that you
have me to tell you what's interesting
about this New York Times article you
have about two sentences from a leak
that this has shifted from an
administrator review to a criminal
investigation and then the New York
Times predictably smears bar smears
doram smears Trump so that's what we're
gonna get from the New York Times we're
not going to get news so it's very
important this is shifted to a criminal
investigation that means they think they
found something Sean they don't just do
that and and so they'll be under attack
they won't be treated like Muller and
his gang of Democrats they'll be under
attack but with a very brave Attorney
General in a very brave US Attorney and
they should just keep at it the rule of
law is what matters I want to spend a
little bit of time that we have actually
going over what the House of
Representatives did when the Republicans
control it in 1998 I think we have some
graphics on this just so the American
people understand the tyrannical process
that's going on with the Democrats in
the House of Representatives what we
have is a rogue Democrat Party in the
House of Representatives that's using
the institution of the house and the
impeachment Clause to interfere with the
2020 election they're interfering with
the 2020 election more than the Russians
did more than the Ukrainians did even
though that was bad enough and they're
using our tax dollars to do it in the
report in October 7 1998 by the
Judiciary Committee to the full house
controlled by the Republicans they said
it is the intention of the committee
that its investigation will be conducted
in all respects on a fair impartial and
bipartisan or nonpartisan basis in this
spirit the
to authorize subpoenas and other
compulsory process is committed by this
resolution in the first instance to the
Chairman and the ranking minority member
acting jointly if either declines the
act the other may act alone subject to
the right of either to refer the
question to the full committee so there
you have an active participation by the
minority party it goes on and this was
presented to the full house for a vote
and it was passed says because the issue
of impeachment is of such overwhelming
importance the committee decided that it
must receive authorization from the full
house before proceeding on any further
course of action because impeachment is
delegated solely to the House of
Representatives by the Constitution the
full House of Representatives should be
involved in critical decision-making
regarding various stages of impeachment
also a resolution authorizing an
impeachment inquiry into the conduct of
a president is consistent with past
practice according to Hynes precedents
the impeachment of President Johnson was
set in motion by a resolution
authorizing a general investigation as
to the execution of the laws they went
on further the impeachment investigation
of President Nixon was explicitly
authorized by the full house during
debate of h.res 803 in 1974 congressman
Rodino then chairman of the committee on
the judiciary stated we have reached the
point when it is important that the
house explicitly confirmed my
responsibility under the Constitution we
are asking the house to authorize and
direct the Committee on the judiciary to
investigate the conduct of the President
of the United States such a resolution
has always been passed by the house the
committee has voted unanimously to
recommend that the House of
Representatives adopt this resolution it
is a necessary step if we are to meet
our obligations they went on so Nixon
and Clinton got treated fairly Trump
gets treated worse than a terrorist or a
mass murder they go on precedent
president's procedural rights prior to
the October 5 committee meeting some
raise concerned about procedural
fairness and encourage the committee to
adopt rule
similar those had topped by the
committee in 1974 with Nixon which would
provide the president with certain
procedural rights after voting on the
hide resolution the committee adopted by
voice vote a number of protections for
the president the president and his
council shall be invited to attend all
executive session and open committee
hearings the President's Council may
cross-examine witnesses the president's
counsel the president's counsel may make
objections the president's counsel
regarding the pert ensue of evidence the
president's counsel should be invited to
suggest that the committee receive
additional evidence lastly the president
or the president's counsel shall be
invited to respond to the evidence
adduced by the committee at an
appropriate time the provisions will
ensure that the impeachment inquiry is
fair to the president I hear some of
these legal analyst analysts out there
going on and on about that's the next
stage no I'm afraid not you didn't have
an official vote on an impeachment
hearing this entire thing is the
Democrat Party in the house seizing
control of the instrumentalities of the
House bastardizing the impeachment
clause in order to drive a trial into
the general election here's a piece from
Politico Wow Ukrainian government
officials this is from January 2017
written by leftists tried to help
Hillary Clinton and undermine Trump by
publicly questioning his fitness for
office they also disseminated documents
implementing their implicating a top
trump aide and corruption and suggested
they were investigating the matter only
to back away after the election and they
helped Clinton allies research damaging
information on trumpet his advisors a
political investigation found it goes in
excruciating detail how the Clinton
campaign how the DNC how the Obama
administration in 2016
worked with the corrupt Ukrainian
government to help Hillary and undermine
the Trump campaign this is why the
president wants to know what they all
happen in 2016 quickly we have testimony
from William Taylor who the hell's
William Taylor all of a sudden he's the
great William
because Adam Schiff has anointed him
such he's a longtime State Department
bureaucrat he's the acting ambassador to
the Ukraine and he talks about among
other things this highly irregular
conduct this second channel with Rudy
Giuliani going around the State
Department because you know does Sean
you can't go around the State Department
well there was a great piece in the in
the real clear investigations and guess
what Sean George Washington had a
private party governor Morris go around
Jefferson in the State Department Bill
Clinton used Jesse Jackson and Bill
Richardson to go around the State
Department Richard Nixon used Arm and
Hammer to go around the State Department
weird Rove Wilson used Edward house to
go around the State Department
Warren Harding used James Logan Jimmy
Carter used Jay Paul Austin Franklin
Roosevelt used Harry Hopkins he so used
Harry Hopkins to set foreign policy
Harry Hopkins had a room in the White
House he took his baths in the White
House he lived in the White House and
yet they're trying to turn Rudy Giuliani
this year regular process when it comes
to presidents of the United States it's
not terribly irregular at all we had the
ex Ukraine ambassador Murray I can't
pronounce her name
Jovanovic she's angry because the
president and his people forced her out
of office excuse me you're an Obama
holdover you should get the hell out of
office we had a new election the
president gets to decide oh and while
we're at it the media you remember Shawn
with the media circled the rag rag
inform the president said to Jim Acosta
effectively you're disrupting these
presidential press conferences you're
pre-madonna this is for the American
people you're not allowed here anymore
remember what the media did they go into
court the media circled the Ragan's they
law this guy's a dictator we the press
we have a right to report on what the
president's doing
we had press associations oh it was a
horrible horrible thing meanwhile
there's still 200 people reporting on
the what the president has done here's
my question where are these press
organizations today when it comes to
Adam Schiff keeping the press out of the
the secret testimony the secret hearings
I gotta go
give a damn anymore do they let me tell
you that's why that book on freedom of
the press was number one forever life
Liberty Levin who'd he got on Sunday
night David Limbaugh who's going to talk
all about the left it's tremendous
alright David the great David Limbaugh
all right and by the way speaking of
David is brother Rush had a great take
today we'll play that